you uh were a renowned atheist i was no
i heard you talk about it and i just
wasn't uh
i believe i've never
gotten any indication that
did you grow up
i grew up yeah 12 years of catholic
school okay and you were an atheist and
you talked about it publicly and then
you had an experience i had an
experience uh
with a plant medicine called ayahuasca
it's a
peruvian
brazilian amazonian
basically two kinds of leaves they make
a brew
and you drink it in a ceremony
and you my understanding of it is that
to me
my experience of it was that it would
say god portal
it's a portal to
talk to the infinite
and you did
uh yeah
and what have we learned
you're going to hell
that was the first thing that i
mentioned uh i mean what did i learn
what i learned was that it's a that it
my that it was a uh
uh that there is
you know uh this is just our human lives
are
part of a continuum
uh i would argue that we are all
infinite spirits
in these human bodies for this finite
amount of time and then we'll go into
we'll become spirits again after this
and um
and
am i i didn't get a lot of
my feeling is that religion is basically
a game of telephone
they've got the basics right that there
is this
power grid
yeah there is a central creation force
but that's about it that's about the
only thing in my experience that they
got correct
but there's no like the rules and the
like the it it is a righteous force and
it is a but the idea that like i'm gonna
punish you for this an accident i didn't
that's not no that's just control yeah
but but so the reason for taking the
ayahuasca was to find this portal the
reason for taking it was was um
was
to deal with depression to deal with
clinical depression and did that work
yeah it did that's amazing you know i
had uh theo vaughn on recently yes i
recommended i recommended i i think he
told me he did
brought him into the game and he's he's
spoken highly and then i got killed
because i was
afraid uh like i didn't know i didn't
know enough about it and even my own
listeners said you know you're not
open-minded i am open-minded now and i i
was wrong and what are you saying it's a
drug and all that stuff well but but i
take drugs right you know
what drugs do you take i'm onzolov oh
yeah
so i was being very old school and stuff
but i'm open to whatever
everybody that i have talked to has
seemed to have a um a positive
outcome somewhat positive outcome or
not negative at least and there are
people you know and i'm a proponent
there are people that can have negative
experiences i've had negative journeys
i've had negative individual journeys do
you do it a lot
i haven't done it in like a year but
uh i had negative individual journeys
that ended up being positive but in them
were
the the
worst experience of my life what is a
bad journey uh i don't know going to um
outer space
and um
dying alone as the universe was was
dying
so you hallucinate you i mean
yeah it's your you're experiencing it
it's a firsthand first person experience
of in this case you're not cognizant of
where your body is and
wow
and that sounds terrifying it's beyond
terrifying but so what's the positive
here's the positive
four or five days later
you have you gone off zone loft
no okay when you go off to
antidepressants whatever it or at least
i won't say you i'll say me when i went
off antidepressants
you have to go off antidepressants to
drink the medicine and and
my the floorboards of my mood
were a little
moldy and soft
like i was off antidepressants and i was
a little like
i could really see myself going into a
dip here right and
after i had that bad experience
the floorboards were firm and polished
and never to be
soft again
is it a permanent fix
so far
how many trips have you taken uh i'd say
about a dozen
they're weekends so so it sounds like a
lot but it's like five weekends so you
do two nights wow you know you heard ron
white quit drinking after he drank iowa
i did not hear that ron white did i
alaska two nights has stopped drinking
owns a tequila company
quit drinking
cold turkey
and he's happy
yeah and apparently he's [ __ ]
hilarious brogan said he's like
sharper than he's ever been
wow so yeah it's a but it's it's a it's
a real
uh
it's it's i i want people people should
approach it with caution because it is
so profound
that it can't it's not a party drug it's
not you can't it's the thing i described
where
you know i'm in outer space and it's
like that's not you can't be talk you i
wasn't able to speak i'm not even there
do you think you were gonna die
um
i thought i was gonna be locked in
like on some pink floyd [ __ ]
uh because before i went to that my
brain
you want to talk about terrifying i
would think the word like i'd go what
and my brain would go i i i i i i i i i
i was like
oh [ __ ] i'm stuck here
and
it but even thinking that i'm stuck was
like proof that i wasn't do you know
what i mean
ours i know you do it with like a shaman
right
shaman
that that's an off-putting word it's the
word people use but like practitioner
do they are they aware that you're in
the guy i've been to three different
shaman or practice don't use that word
it's get that word has no place in this
family
um
i've been to three and
one is very good and one two or so one
out of three isn't
yeah it's not great well again that's
the
yeah so i could talk to you for hours
and hours you're probably one of those
fascinating try me try me [ __ ]
i dare you
[Music]
you